the deputy prime minister dominic rabb
joins me now live from westminster good
to talk to you this morning sir um let's
just start straight away with the
zapparosha nuclear plant and the attack
on it um we have heard just now from the
ministry of defense that radiation
levels are normal but how concerned are
you about the fact that that this plan
was
hit do you think it was targeted or was
this this this just part of warfare
well at the very
at the very least it was clearly a
reckless bombardment of a very sensitive
and precarious and dangerous facility
and the fact that the russians kept
bombarding it after
um
there was the fire and the ukrainian
emergency rescue team were trying to get
to that
makes it doubly reprehensible
the prime minister has been very clear
on this
he's called for an emergency meeting of
the un security council
in new york in order to
ramp up the pressure on these appalling
tactics that we're seeing from the
kremlin but also to make sure we're
supporting the ukrainian government in
any way we can
does this perhaps suggest to you that
president putin is serious about nuclear
war
i think the way i would read it is that
the early part of his military campaign
has stuttered and stumbled it's not been
as effective uh i think there's been a
lot of pushback um
amongst the russians that this isn't
what they uh had expected this isn't
what he'd sold he'd said it would be a
cake walk into ukraine that clearly
hasn't happened and he's responding with
ever more heavy-handed and brutal um uh
tactics and that is also i think a
reflection of the fact that the
international community has been more
resolute than perhaps he'd expected with
the concerted package of sanctions which
has had a a a very uh an initially very
powerful impact on for example the
russian ruble the russian stock market
they've had to in double interest rates
uh so we will continue to uh starve the
finances that that fund putin's war
machine and support ukrainians in their
uh their courageous defense against this
illegal invasion
but whilst it may well be impacted on
some russians it doesn't seem to be
changing president putin's mind any does
it
well it won't happen overnight we need
to keep up the pressure uh which is why
we're taking the actions that we're
taking but it has had an immediate
impact and of course um and we need to
show the strategic stamina to see this
through in ukraine uh and of course
it is dawning on uh many whether it's
the conscripts who are out there in
ukraine told that they were a
peacekeeping force facing fearsome
resistance uh
receiving illegal orders to attack
civilian targets which could end
up seeing them
in the dock of a court or even
imprisoned for war crimes and of course
those who are bankrolling putin are
being hit where it hurts as well but
you're right to say it's not going to
happen overnight i think we need to get
set
for a much longer protracted crisis in
you
in ukraine and we'll need to have the
stamina with our international partners
for that
are you concerned about president
putin's state of mind
i look i think it's clearly irrational
even if i looked at it through the
narrowest russian
uh perspective clearly counterproductive
to russian interest and you can see that
in the economic consequences and i
believe you'll see that in the the
casualties that they're taking will
continue to take
i've got no idea i'm not a psychiatrist
but it is clearly irrational and
counterproductive for russians let alone
the impact the horrific impact it's
having on the people of your ukraine and
the wider nervousness we've all got now
around uh regional security
how concerned are you about president
zielenski in ukraine and what help can
the uk give to him because he has become
such a galvanizing figure quite an
inspirational figure inside ukraine we
know that he has been targeted
by russian forces
if he were to be
attacked or if he was forced to leave
what impact do you think that would have
on the conflict
well we know that the
russian playbook has involved targeted
assassinations we've seen that in the
streets of salisbury in 2018 so i i
think we do need to support
president zlensky in every way we can of
course we give him advice and
we'll be careful about divulging too
much of that but we also give him
military hardware we've given his
troops uh training under operation
orbital
and there's a a massive package of uh
economic and humanitarian support for
him as well um so we won't i won't go
into too much
of some of the finer details of it but
we are willing to do whatever it takes
to support
the ukrainian defense and indeed the
president in what is a very courageous
stance that he's taking
what does that mean
i'll just explain to you what it
involves
you won't give us any more details on
exactly what the uk is sending to help
ukrainians on this front
we've uh provided anti-tank uh um uh
hardware uh we're continuing and willing
to provide other military hardware to
allow ukrainians to defend themselves
we provided humanitarian assistance on
top of the economic assistance to deal
with obviously the energy pressures
that they will face
and we'll look across the board at what
else we can do and we're going to
support the international criminal court
uh the chief prosecutor i believe is
going to ukraine uh if we can support
that accountability and and it's
critical that evidence of war crimes is
preserved so that those responsible
right across the chain of command can be
held accountable so from from from war
crimes through to humanitarian
assistance through to the hardware to
defend the streets and the cities of
ukraine we will provide whatever we can
and of course
the most important thing is to work with
our allies to make it as effective as
possible
you mentioned sanctions let's go back
back to them france and germany have
already started seizing oligarchs yachts
shouldn't we be seizing property as tom
tugan hard has suggested
well we have got sanctions on over a
hundred entities you've seen two
individuals isn't loving chivalrous
overnight
but what we're doing is making sure we
take the most effective measures uh we
need evidence to seize
property um and just to give you one
illustration because it's been put about
that we're slow or we're lagging behind
actually we've sanctioned more russian
banks than the eu including the biggest
russian banks burbank
we've prevented
millions of russian companies from being
listed in the uk or raising loans in the
uk
and we will look carefully at how we can
expedite and strengthen all the the the
powers that we've got so just to give
you two examples on monday we're going
to be putting through at pace the
economic crimes bill which will
strengthen the unexplained wealth orders
and create greater transparency around
who owns foreign-owned companies who is
the ultimate owner
in order for us to take faster and more
effective measures but we've got one of
the most robust and rigorous sanctions
regimes in the world we do need to have
a legal basis and evidence to take those
measures otherwise you end up tripping
up and that just gives a propaganda coup
to whoever we want to target and of
course i would also just say we're not
targeting all international uh finance
coming into the uk we want to be open to
that we're not targeting blanket uh
russian uh money we are targeting
the corrupt the kleptocrats and those
linked to putin and his war machine and
it's very important that we are targeted
in what we do because that's the most
effective way to increase the squeeze on
vladimir putin and his war machine
back in 2010 the conservative government
changed the visa system to encourage
more high net worth individuals to come
into the uk in hindsight do you think
that that was possibly an error that
that possibly has has led to a blind eye
being turned to some
russian money that perhaps shouldn't
have done coming into the uk
well the home sector has already dealt
with the tier one um
visas and uh it's true to say that we
want to be open to business and open to
international investment it's part of
our usp and global britain but at the
same time we have led the way in taking
targeted sanctions just to give you two
further illustrations particularly
relevant to russia as foreign secretary
uh i introduced the sergey magnitsky
sanction regime for human rights abuses
asset visas asset freezes and visa bans
and we extended it to corruption so we
have been at the vanguard of striking
this balance between being an open
economy but not allowing dirty money and
and and those with blood on their hands
to place their assets here and we're
strengthening that even further
okay
good to talk to you dominic rob thanks
very much for joining us today